[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today next we
have Cody in Lancaster Pennsylvania hey
Cody welcome to the show hey Rachel hey
John it's good to hear from you guys I I
must admit it's a great birthday gift to
be able to talk to you guys I'm pretty
excited happy birthday happy Cody how
old are you man birthday's not till
tomorrow but yeah it's exciting for me
I've been listening I'm a new listener
but how old are you I do enjoy listening
to you guys 29 tomorrow nice hey you're
going to be 29 for the next 30 years of
your life congratulations that's awesome
that's what my mom keeps saying she's
been 29 for about 30 years or something
like that yeah she loves being 29 it's
great I got a bit of a bit of a two-part
question for you guys if that's okay
it's it's one question but I I don't
even know really how to ask it in one
thing so I I bought a um I I started a
job in insurance and in uh 2019 we moved
out to Pennsylvania my wife's family
lives here and we lived with her parents
for a little while and and we had a
brand new baby at the time and that was
absolutely toxic and I had to get out of
it so we we wanted to buy as well
because we've been renting for so long
and at the time like we'll be close to
family so we wanted to buy anyway just
to be in the state and grow my business
but we bought a house that's more of
like your your first home buy it checked
all the boxes we needed but as as the
last three years have gone on we are we
don't really love the house we're
realizing we like more space we kind of
think that we want to move but the
reason I had this question every time I
listen to the show is because when I
bought the house I didn't have two years
of consecutive work hisory because I'm
self-employed so my dad offered to put
his name on the house I know how the
Ramy family feels about I know I know I
know don't Hur me but I didn't so I I've
only been listening to you guys for a
little bit but I know when I listen and
I I I would never do it now nor would I
ever ever ask him to do it again and
I've already apologized to him for doing
it and he makes buckets of money out in
California doing what he's doing anyway
but it it's not a problem for him and
he's never paid a single dollar at all
from our house a down payment anything
his name just had to be on the thing in
order for us to get it sure so the idea
was to get the house after I worked for
two years refinance it but we're sitting
here now three years later and interest
rates have more than tripled so I I'm
like is it it sounds so dumb to
refinance it I I'm I'm a little torn
because I want his name off of it even
though he doesn't need his name off of
it it's not hurting him right the bills
have never gone unpaid we do our job but
I just I my three options that I kind of
come to are are refinance or stack the
deck until we're ready to get the new
house which takes some time obviously or
just pay it off uh in the next three
three and a half to four years because
my income goes up quite a bit each each
year sure um I'm not I'm just not even
sure what to do but I just I'm like is
it wrong to hang him on the loan or what
but how much how much are you how much
do you owe on the
house uh about 180 85 185 okay and how
much you make a
year uh well see that's the thing so my
my income is doubled over the last two
years and I get about a $40,000 increase
each year
um but on I would say you have the last
few years and you hope to get in the
future yes be very careful about making
guys with yeah don't make financial
decisions based on this yeah in 14 years
I'm gonna be making right be careful
about that right right and that's why I
don't want to I don't want to go into
like a really expensive house or
anything we also we're we're minimal
people we don't need a lot to be happy
but our our income now I I'd say by the
end of this year we'll probably clock in
just under I'd say probably somewhere
around 90 um um and then yeah because
the majority of of everything that I
make I get a giant bonus in January
depending on how annual enrollment
period goes for Medicare because I do I
do mostly Medicare okay so I get a huge
influx in the beginning of the year and
then I get like a monthly payment
through the rest of the year so I have
to spread it out I'm good at saving
because I have to spread myself out in
order to live so sure after that point
do you guys have any other
Deb uh no other debt well all right
that's lied um I we have a car that's
going to be completely paid off in Jan
well in December is going to be paid off
okay completely so other than that we
just have a house okay and you said I've
done the math I cut you off but uh well
after I've done the math and I know John
just corrected me not to do that but
I've done the math in a conservative
manner as though I'm going to be
increasing my income only half of what
I've been increasing at the last three
years uh at about a $20,000 increase
because I just I like to do my numbers
extremely conservatively sure and it it
should only take
us about three to four years to to pay
off the house my numbers I mean honestly
we I don't know what to do if I get his
name off of it or or if there's a way to
do that without refinancing it just
seems so dumb to refinance with such
high interest rates right now right no I
hear you yeah and I think if you talk to
your mortgage broker I mean maybe
there's a way around it you know there
sometimes they have different stuff but
I mean I don't I don't know if that's
going to be for you but I mean there's
there's Parton me Cody and I'm going to
just say it that I'm like listen you got
you're not going to have this house for
15 years you guys have an aggressive
plan want the house yeah you have an
aggressive plan to pay it off um you
sound as you're talking to us like
you're on track there's not been a
situation so far with your dad and all
that go ahead go ahead cuz I got I'm I'm
kind of burning here go ahead go well
well I I was going to say I mean like I
want to hear I want to hear the fire
throw me down no we're not going to
throw you down I mean I would look I
would run the math and just see okay how
how much extra yeah because if your if
your interest rate is going to be you
know 7% versus 2% or whatever 5% what
how much extra is that how much longer
would that take you and you guys need to
really run these numbers out and you and
your wife need to sit down and ask okay
is the extra tens of thousands whatever
it is dollars that we're going to pay if
we refinance to get him off and and
clean slated you know what is it worth
it to us is that because right now it
doesn't sound like the relationship is
overly strained it doesn't sound like
he's he's a toxic person and you and you
because there's there are people that
call Cody listen though and and it goes
down the drain right that's is why we
tell people not to do this because it
can go down the drain really really fast
and so if you were in a situation we get
this a lot where it's like oh my gosh
you know my her name's on it and she's
doing this and wanting this and telling
me here and and it's just a disaster I
would be like no am and I would get out
of it no matter the interest rate
because of the toxic relationship but
what you're saying is you're in
Pennsylvania he's in
California there's you guys seem to that
it's okay like you guys from a
relationship standpoint there hasn't
been this big you know explosion and
you're going to pay it off in three
years so all of that I would be
comfortable Cody if you just keep keep
going down the track and pay it off in 3
years and be done with it again if the
timeline was different if the
relationship different my answer
probably would change yeah I dude I hear
one word pay it off when we when we
don't really I I know but listen I hear
one word and that is
ego you said it you know what you said
it while Rachel was talking I just want
this personal accomplishment bro you
took out alone with your daddy with your
daddy's signature on
it it would almost be irresponsible
right
now for you to flex your ego to the tune
of however many thousands of dollars
that your ego would cost you and to keep
going your ego says I just got a $40,000
raise I'm going to get a $40,000 next
year and a 40 year after that and a year
after that what you haven't experienced
is there is usually when you get into an
industry there's a low bar and then you
do a really great job and you go way up
and then you go way up again but it does
begin to
plateau and while we're at it your ego
says I make $90,000 a year we don't need
this little house we need some something
that better reflects us and and so what
I want you to do is to take your ego and
put it in a drawer and say what is best
for our family right now in this
season and let's go from there because
I'm a I'm super nervous that you have
gone over the next five years and giving
yourself a $40,000 raise in your mind
put that on paper and you and your wife
have talked about the house you could
afford and I think that's not
real and that you've reversed engineered
that fantasy all the way back to this
discomfort with your dad's name is still
on your
loan well I have to admit I we're really
not I we bought this one at 185 and
we're actually thinking of coming closer
to you guys Tennessee Arkansas and with
what we're looking at it really would
only run somewhere between 200 to 250
which is what our house is kind of going
for right now okay so you you'd keep
that flat which would be awesome good
for you and y'all moving that's awesome
too I I'm with I'm with Rachel I would
ride this thing out it sounds like
you're dad's a great guy and is not
abusing this relationship I would ride
this out until yall are are committed to
what your next steps are and I just PID
the sucker off yep